hey david we see more and more sexual
assault allegations and sexual
harassment allegations against
candidates and it seems to matter less
than ever
do voters even care about sexual
harassment
anymore i think that this is a an
interesting question
for a couple of different reasons it
does seem as though
lately candidates and other prominent
people
get hit with allegations of sexual
harassment or sexual assault
they don't drop out or resign or go into
therapy or whatever you know there's
different ways that it's sometimes
handled
and they still sort of do okay i mean
donald trump is example number one
accused by
you know 16 to 48 different women at
different points in time
and didn't drop out and was elected
president period
uh there was that special election in
alabama where republican roy moore who
was accused of harassing underage women
lost by only a point and a half in 2017.
now
a republican losing by 1.5 in alabama
is a big deal because it's such a red
state but
it didn't completely knock him out of
the running if a couple things went a
little differently he still would have
won
andrew cuomo he has been accused of all
sorts of improper
touching and verbal comments by multiple
women
he has said at least for now he's not
going to resign even if he's not cleared
by the attorney general report
he's made public appearances with other
legislative leaders
some of whom called for him to resign
but
about half of new yorkers don't think he
should resign that includes 61 percent
of democrats
uh it's still currently under the
investigation phase but we've seen
people resign during investigations
before and it's not
clear it's having a major impact some of
the coveted mishandling is
with the nursing home uh scandal we
talked about previously but he's just
still kicking around
matt gates now matt gates allegedly paid
for sex from underage women for whom he
paid
to go from one state to another which
legally counts as sex trafficking
not facing too many calls to resign
the republican caucus is basically
behind him
um it's not clear whether it's going to
affect him unless he's actually charged
and even then we're going to wait and
see
during the brett kavanaugh confirmation
hearings to the supreme court
he maintained very high republican
support
uh after um christine blasey
blasey ford testified um
brett kavanaugh's approval from
republicans went up even if i recall
correctly
so there's a couple different things
going on here we
sort of knew a lot of people didn't
really care
but increasingly it seems as though
it's not playing a role in politics
where there are more people taking the
approach of
it depends who you talk to but a lot of
democrats taking the approach of
if republicans aren't going to hold them
accountable
why are we going to go crazy the al
franken situation comes to mind where
compared to the things republicans have
been accused of
and just stuck it out al franken's
resignation
is now seen as premature by many given
what he was accused of an untasteful
joke
for tasteless joke no no doubt about it
but comparatively
you've seen a lot of democrats say hey
let's not go crazy because they're not
doing anything about these allegations
on their side
i think republican voters genuinely
don't care they have taken a sort of
greater good mentality
of yeah even if we're evangelical
christians we'll still elect the guy
with the multiple wives and the cheating
and the divorce and the mistresses and
whatever
because democrats are just worse in
general and they support abortion and
whatever
so they justify it that way so i think
that while individuals
in their lives care about sexual
harassment and sexual assault
i think politically it is less of a
successful or effective
hatchet to end someone's career and
that's a result
both of some aspects from the right and
some aspects from the left
although the left has been far more
consistent when it came to al franken
anthony weiner
in just abandoning the accused people i
think some sort of real politic
type pragmatic perspective lately is
making even some on the left
uh reconsider whether we should just
leave the sexual harassment to
that's the personal life of the
individual and at least
claim that it has nothing to do with
their
actions as an elected official if you
ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an ebook
or audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video